okay for those joining this livestream
we are talking about the entity
framework for Wolfram language and
entities are things in the real world
mostly um and let's see I think we've
we've we were primarily trying to talk
about the way of generalizing
hierarchies of entities and so on I
think we've we've talked about it was
was a second party or not not this one
okay um all right um okay so what we had
talked about last time um we got some
background I said by the way um I had to
do with this notion of domains of
discourse and I think what we were
talking about was let's see um but let's
let's
can somebody summarize here we were
talking about um entity types all
entities of that type have the same set
of properties defined and we're talking
about um the question of how for example
a species can have as sub entity types
um
yeah how does this work what is our what
is our way of thinking about that we
were discussing like what is the
relation between they named entity
classes and own entity types that are
subtypes that's one of the discussion
where we didn't have come to totally
clear conclusions right um
right so let me just go and put this in
my place you might want to adjust your
microphone um okay
so let's talk through the question of of
species for example so we have you know
potentially we have an entity type that
is um well an entity of type mammal
which we don't have right now right and
the whole point of that is that that
almost everything you know in a given
entity type has that the set of
properties will be usually not missing
or not non defined for most of the
things in that given entity um and but I
think
idea here about domains of discourse
there's what I think like if we have
something that is a little bit under
specified that the domains of discourse
tells us what it actually is which
viewpoint to take to consider this think
okay but how does that relate to the
entity specification I mean so so
there's a notion of okay so here we have
entity types right lots of entities that
have common a common common common set
of properties um and we're
um nothing similar also shares all those
properties
right so in other words if you're saying
an entity of type mammal that's
because for a mammal you can ask things
like you know what's their gestation
period which makes no sense if it's a
reptile or something right but and there
is um and similarly if you're dealing
with a a book you can ask things like
how big is it which makes no sense if
you're dealing with a work because that
is the abstract content of you know Gone
with the Wind you don't you don't get to
ask how big is it how many entries is it
across it's a it's a non question so to
speak
makes sense yep okay now the question is
how do we maintain what does it mean
when we have this hierarchies of of
concepts effectively so for instance um
Ethan our live stream is pointing out
that we we currently have a
representation for the class of mammals
which is an entity of addint that's an
entity what the heck is that what is
that is that an entity class it is it's
an entity that's a mess yes and we we're
already doing it okay okay all right so
hierarchy of concepts so we've got
mammal and certain properties of mammal
are
relevant now what was our idea here I'm
sorry I'm um I think the idea of or
something like you have I think you had
some gold or something and so what is
called is it is it then Adam is it an
isotope and you had this domain of
discourse that kind of gives you a hint
and the true point you want to see it I
see so so in other words we might have a
notion here of a concept so we might
imagine something like a we might
imagine something a concept that is
um and then we might have a domain here
and then something like whatever it is
gold or something I don't know that's
the right thing to imagine it has and
then this becomes then that has multiple
entities that correspond to that concept
with different what's that
I mean II inherited suggestion which I
liked which is slightly similar we have
a one argument form gold that then can
be instantiated to a two argument and if
suggestion that was entity gold like
this that then depending on the domain
of discourse instantiates to I see
well surf already does this but not like
that
surf has this notion the semantic
relations framework has the notion of
entity type hierarchies and what is a
member of what and also abstract entity
types and so you might have an abstract
entity type of a character with concrete
instantiations that are person and
fictional character and those are you
know two separate branches and then
under person you can have NFL player and
MLB player and so on and of course it's
possible for someone like Deion Sanders
to be both an NFL player and an MLB
player more than I know but yes okay
yeah for called and Jason assists expert
in this according to the Papa I you park
nomenclature like they are not really at
all hierarchically there are also a lot
of next to each other like gold as a
Edom versus gold as an iron and so on
yes I understand so Jeremy tell me what
the design of what's now in the surf is
well I tried to just explain that but
also it's not actually designed in terms
of function names and so on
oh I see yeah so so the put so so at the
entity head is used there although
slightly differently Oh actually not not
that differently so it is in fact the
entity and then the type comma the
standard name and it is always two
arguments entity we don't have the
single argument entity that Michael just
mentioned but of course it's possible
that the the serf realizes that if
you're referring to entity MLB player
Deion Sanders then because of the
hierarchy that's the same entity as the
person Deion Sanders okay I want to know
how is this entity hierarchy what
actually happens I mean in other words
no sir right right so so it means that
Deion Sanders by virtue of being these
things has all of the person relation
all the person properties it has all the
all the character properties if we
actually had that abstract entity type
it would okay okay I get it but I want
to know what the actual function names
are and so on that the right so so see
notable chemistry problems that's pretty
stupid right that's pretty stupid and
probably is not you know yes and no I
would say that's the interesting case is
it stupid or is it not it's stupid in in
a in a park Matic sense definitely but
not in app stores I would know I agree
okay okay but but then you know
it's not stupid in the same sense as how
many Finn's does a camel have is not
stupid
exactly exactly in this particular case
this is the wrong answer the correct
answer is he didn't have any correct
um but of course unfortunately it is
very hard for all the professions to
properly create really what each
individual has achieved so it's very
hard for us to differentiate in some
sense yeah I mean like like for instance
here you know it could be that van Gogh
had discovered some pigmentation you
know some music maybe a trance yes it's
called some chemical sink right okay but
let's come back to how the current self
implementation works right so I I don't
have all the function names off the top
of my head and I'm not going to clean
that there's a one-to-one correspondence
either between how the serf operates and
how the Wolfram language entities work
but that there is a notion of entity
type hierarchy there's a notion you can
ask if a particular entity belongs to a
particular entity type there's no notion
of entity classes instead entity classes
are just another entity type and so
that's how you get mammals as an entity
class of species is just by having the
entities belong to that entity type as
well so it really is a hierarchy
and this is also a subtle topic like
most people would probably don't think
members as an entity but say this out
your LMS and are not to meet the
standard explicitly specified they are
entities even if they have some entities
so what exactly constitute the entity
versus the entity class really depends
on the domain of science who specifies
the building well let me give an example
of that for example you know a bat or no
no let's say sharks okay um ah you know
I might say it's a shock but actually
there are you know that's just a random
cartilaginous fish there are many many
many different kinds of sharks so to
speak and there what's my point a shark
could be thought of as an entity but in
fact there are many sub entities right
so a shark I know to me fva finger-like
which of the ten I see might be an
entity or an entity class yeah well I
think that um I mean maybe Tony can say
something about the the RDF view of all
this stuff
Joan herre so in rdf there are no
restrictions you can use any object as
entity or S Class however in owl which
builds on top or can be expressed in
order now you have a little bit stronger
sing so you can declare a sing as either
being a named individual or a class but
then this whole - you can also do this
cunning where you can define the certain
iri is both a named individual and the
class but depending on the context it's
always clear which aspect this mint and
to give an example a person can be of a
certain profession now so in this case
profession is a class now to which
certain persons belong but then the
person a profession can also be an
instance a named entity that has
properties by themselves for instance
what two instances of that thing - what
do people of a certain profession do
that could be a property ok so they
haven't solved any problems there and I
think there's one more to point on this
like it is an entity or no entity class
as you written and then as we currently
do with the implicit entities in food it
is an entity that arises through some
kind of course Connie
I see it's like when you say it's a
chart you don't mean average overall
sharks but if you say here's a
chocolate-chip cookie in the absence of
any fossil information it is an average
chocolate-chip cookie yes
actually we're still an average cookie
um okay all right so let's go back here
to thinking about what it means to have
this concept of
see ya I don't even know what this is I
mean there's this try some translation
of natural language or what the heck is
this because this has so many different
things with different you know the gold
let's not pick gold you know that the
the copper ion you know the +1 ion the
plus 2 ion all this kind of thing and
they might all be being referred to as
copper right I mean one of the advantage
of this upstart one is if we would apply
a property that say comes form a certain
entity type as we had this summers with
the masses of exoplanets planets blah
blah blah there then we could insert yes
based on that the poverty comes from yes
having a type mismatch well so long as
we know the data because the whole point
is an entity type has the feature that
it is a thing that conceptually can be
stored in an entity store and where the
entity store is not terribly ragged
where the entity property value table of
the entity store is not terribly ragged
that make sense yep I mean okay so
assume that that's the case so we have
um you know astronauts for example their
you know which space mission they were
on what um you know how many days in
space they've been right all those kinds
of things mr. van Gogh doesn't get a
days in space in a literal sense um you
know field it's irrelevant but so we've
got within an entity type we have this
somewhat rectangular collection of
properties and values now the question
is what is the inheritance structure of
one entity type to others in other words
see see I think we're getting a little
bit confused because in the case of an
astronaut case of a person a singular
thing right then we can there is a view
of that singular thing as an astronaut
there is a view of that singular thing
as a business executive for example but
that's different from the situation
where we have um where it might be a
shark that particular shark the one that
washed up on such-and-such a beach
versus a shark in general or a shark of
a certain species and so on does that
make sense so I mean there there look I
think there are there are kind of um
views of things as in a person viewed as
an astronaut versus a business is
graduate --iv and then there are things
where it's where there's something about
um the
[Music]
of the thing itself a particular shark
you know named Fred versus um a shark of
a certain species um
and so on I mean there's the average an
average shock
etc so how do we view so I mean this
this notion of a view of things that's
like taking a single I mean what does
that what does that mean I mean then we
would have an entity a person entity of
whatever it is you know Neil Armstrong
or something right here and then that
somehow would be then we would also have
entity astronaut and then that would
have that name and then we've got to
associate one with the other right yep
now perhaps what happens is that this
has simply a property which is some kind
of parent it might not be parent entity
I mean this is where it's more like a
graph well the way we do that is by
actually marking the entity itself as
being a member of that particular entity
type right it's the same it to me at
least it seems like it's the same issue
of Deion Sanders being an NFL player and
an MLB player but not an NBA player
yeah I understand so this one could
certainly in train you know that it has
various sub various you know I don't
know what they all are related types or
something right and then well well and
and usually it is a hierarchy that the
thing that's tricky here is that
astronauts can be persons but of course
there were also monkey astronauts but
not every but yet not every person what
is an astronaut so figuring out exactly
how that hierarchy should work it
becomes tricky yeah ok consider consider
like a the astronaut dog um ok but you
see I'm not even sure again this is part
of our definition of things each one of
these things would be you know we get to
document it and when we say entity type
astronaut we can define that to be a
human astronaut if we want to
sure that that non intersection will
always work um okay but but let's let's
go back here I'm actually we've got some
interesting comments on the live stream
let's take a look at these Nicola says
natural language does not differentiate
between an object and the property of it
Gold for instance is it a thing that has
property or is it a property of
something
how did she see I think that's the yeah
natural language can be complicated
because things which are used as you
know things can be used both as nouns
and adjectives we get to define what
they actually know we're leveraging
natural language but we are making a
precise symbolic language and we get to
say for example in the case of astronaut
is the definition
you know what would I what I'm imagining
is that for every one of these entity
types there is a almost a legal contract
that says what we think that entity type
is if that makes sense right and so for
example in the astronaut one we might
say part of that contract which
hopefully one day we could write in a
symbolic language itself we are saying
that you know the astronaut is human or
the astronaut may be of any speech I
mean an astronaut presumably presumably
an AI cannot be an astronaut I'm making
sense anybody want to comment on that I
mean so in other words um is a paying
passenger on a commercial spacecraft an
astronaut
good question
um we are entering that era yeah
definitely but I mean so look that's my
whole point my whole point is every one
of these entity types gets a contract
associated with it that defines what
kind of a thing it is and that contract
will be written in English right now
hopefully one day we can make it more
you know more symbolic but for the time
being we write that we define it and it
might change over time actually they're
our next comment from cheezy on the
livestream is what if an entity changes
over time for example an NFL player
who's never played baseball now becomes
an MLB player as well right I don't
think that's a huge problem I mean I
think that that we have that case now
with companies for example right well I
mean even with the sports people there
are people who've played one
professional sport and then they later
tried another professional sport we have
we have data for them that covers the
period when they were playing in one
sport and when they play in the other
sport we have data that covers that
period right right now we qualify
properties and this works for most
things pretty reasonable but maybe in
the future we have to qualify entities
what do you mean by that
like the dated France 1980 it is as
natural to consider it as a qualifier
for France rather than a qualifier for
the poverty or population but we allow
that don't we you can really make any
sense they get a sense that you can rap
dated around an entity yes I mean but
that all that is is a convenient way
because then that just over though the
insight okay so if I say this for
example and then I say that GDP for
example then you're saying that what's
really happening internally is that
that's turning into France and then it's
a dated property exactly exactly
okay okay I mean there's also one could
imagine things that change in space come
or not
um what's an example of that there would
be harder I feel like to define the
identity of a think if it changes in
space me think about that for a second
um Papa Papa okay here's an example um
an amphibious car
it's do that in India fair enough fair
enough I mean it's just a different view
of it it's a boat it's a um okay let's
see Nicola says a shot can be a person
too because we don't differentiate
between things and properties I'm quite
understand that I'm somehow reminded of
that scene in the Finding Nemo movie
that um wait a minute what was it fish
of food no what was that scene it says
something like that it's a it's the
equivalent of tail and what is it it's
the arrows named work if there's no
short tail and it's not syringe Oh your
friends not through Karen right the UM
the UM okay Karl says suppose the thing
is that a wiki data and so on you can
add properties like atomic mass to the
Stephen Wolfram entity you just have
rules on a property that disallow it
you
yeah I don't even understand I mean that
that that has to do with the non
properties question of you know a bird
can't have fins type thing um
let's see
ah Nicola the idea of contract is
interesting because somehow it defines
the entity used in the real world
yeah as Pritikin stein yes yes this is
this is a deeply you know this is where
all the vit consign stuff you know it's
not a question of just talking about it
we actually have to write code um ok if
you look at the position played on team
slash specialty you can see how wiki
data handles temporal changes ok we
could look at one of those I suppose
ha what a mess I see
yeah okay so there's a start time and an
end time for each for each thing right
so we could imagine I mean
yeah I don't even understand that I mean
in in okay so there's a the notion of a
discrete changes over time
how do we represent that so that would
be eg and this relates to temporal logic
as well
eg played in a certain position in 2001
to 2005 another position order actually
not even that in a certain position
promoted to another position how are we
doing this for leader data each each
time that the entities in the current
leader data are essentially 10 years
like each each entity is a is a
particular person in a position
associated with a particular and
treasurer whatever it so so that's the
analog so in other words if we talk
about the case of people okay then we
might have just like we have four books
the work the book the manifestation well
actually this is generally hierarchies
so so we might say they're um you know
four books we have um the work the book
the manifestation you know and that
would be as we say you know you know
Gone with the Wind
then the book is second edition
hardcover maybe there's even a generic
book and then the manifestation is the
British Museum copy British Library I
guess it is now copy right and then for
people you're saying well there's also
there's people and positions so we have
a notion of a what is it it it's
complicated we have a tenure for example
right
eg a person in a certain position for a
certain period because they might be
president twice or something for making
sense exactly um okay
you
and
okay all right but but I think we don't
have really and maybe we're getting this
in the temporal logic world we don't
really have a an equivalent
I mean we have event series right and we
have event series which has discrete
events happening what we don't have
really is a
what would I might call a sequence of
states series
if I'm making sense that is that you
feed to it it's like a piecewise right
it's like piecewise it says given the
time given these intervals in time this
is the state of the system for these
intervals in time discrete states but in
a sequence of intervals in time
how come we have time serious with the
revelation order zero which assumes
constant states between Clare enough
it's still a little bit too limiting in
the sense of that it mostly wants kind
of some numeric array like object inside
it doesn't it can't represent some more
complicated state of things like that
the procedure that Andrew was working on
is a little bit more in this direction
which Andrew yes okay um so I mean
there's this notion of a dated series so
that in which there are time intervals
and there are states roughly I mean that
would be one way to think about this
this is sort of a form of categorical
data which one can imagine could be fed
into timeline plots and all that kind of
thing right because this is what is the
relationship between this and a date
okay so there's also the notion of a
date interval right which we that's
coming yeah we're working on that right
so that would be the thing that but then
a date interval and a dated series dated
series is a little bit like it's not a
recurring you know a dated series could
break up into a bunch of it is date
intervals together with payloads right I
still think this should be represented
by a time serious yeah I know but we
there's no reason to call it that it
will just confuse the heck out of people
to quit but what's it that's in think
it's too complicated it's like there's
no reason that various intervals are
even mutually exclusive the promise we
are discussing about this state that
series already exists in time serious on
but I did it doesn't allowed to have two
things at one point but that second the
notion of a combiner function you have
to specify with how to choose the first
one or but I'm not sure that Michael
Michael thinks there might be two
overlapping he safety things we're in
two states the NBA Day events for NF
Elias Bo's right right right right right
so at a particular time the dated series
might have a pair of values eg I mean
it's so edgy CEO of company one and
company two so for example if I say what
is this person's position they might be
you know they might have a whole list of
positions at a given time which then at
some later time would be would resolve
to a single position for example or not
so in fact one would suspect that the
way this should work is that at any
given time so it's a thing date interval
so what this would be is something where
you ask for a particular time
I mean actually this could be done for
like interpolation as well I mean
there's that there's a version of this
that it's just like interpolation ok
separate design ok sub sub sub thing
here so what we've got we could imagine
something where it's a what the heck is
this this is a what is this well let's
call it let's call the function foo for
now um let's say um
so you get what it's saying it's saying
for this interval
it's basically
I'm gonna try this name I don't think
it's quite right but so the notion is
that it is a thing
where you give it a list of intervals
and that has payload 1 right
is this like piecewise is this basically
piecewise no because PDF is basically we
cannot have overlaps I see
and so then the idea would be
um but instant disagree so if these wise
resolves to returning different types
then this is like big but the example
that is right now in the screen how
would you resolve this what is to be at
the what is the value at 4.5 exactly so
that's the question so what do we want
to return what I'm saying is that once
we decide what to return we can't write
it with this wise now we can't know we
called yes because we would say from 1
to 3
oh yeah we can resolve it into a
piecewise that is correct yes that we
can resolve in it or piecewise but it
isn't naturally a piecewise it's yeah
it's not but but it can be resolved too
so it can be represented as a piecewise
sure so then then the way this would
work is this interval function would be
given a particular value say 5 or
something and then it would return a
null list or it could return a list with
with many you know Val for Val 7 etc now
one might even want it and this is gets
more complicated to have a function to
have these things on the right-hand side
not be values but be functions of the
actual value
all right but let's let's come back over
here so then we might want the an N
there could also be a dated version as
well but this does seem somewhat useful
this this notion of overlapping values
now of course we could also imagine a
two dimensional generalization of this
and the 2d generalization we would have
to have instead of intervals we
basically have regions is this something
you know what what about this four
regions so in other words we're saying
in this region this is the you know that
this is a sensible thing gosh however
we've not had this before in this region
lions live in this region elephants live
what lives at this point yeah what I'm
saying
so I think this is a bit what the new
polygons do do you have different types
of polygons and just specify rules that
say what happens in developing regions
yeah I agree but I think this is a
packaging okay so okay this is an
interesting thing we should put that off
to one side for a minute okay let's come
back to our main topic all right so the
issue is we've got
a thing like an ant an astronaut entity
and we want to be able to
I mean given that you asked for it given
that you have that thing and now you
asked for a property of that thing like
for example the age or the the birth
date of that entity astronaut entity
what should happen is that
the birthdate is a property associated
with a person entity and somehow that
thing should be able to find in both
directions if you say given the person
entity you say how many space missions
have they been on given the astronaut
entity what was their date of birth
I'm making sense yep
if they're a person were both say the
basketball player and the baseball
player who keeps track of which one
sports games are in or do you get the
combination of both wait a second if you
if you ask a question so does it okay so
each property is associated with a given
entity type right that's right so a
given property type given property is
associated with an entity type right so
if we say something like latest game or
something or sports games whoever's
typing please me yourself
um the what will have to happen
ultimately is it's got to generate an
assuming of some kind it doesn't know
otherwise how could it know in other
words if we've got entity
okay entity person I don't know any
sports figures Sports mr. sports okay
and then then we've got entity MLB
player mister sports
ah what is it and and NBA NBA okay um
okay okay so then any property like
latest game or something or games played
would be an entity property of please
don't type in our ear come on to the UM
okay oh look at that we've even got that
property there okay so that's that
entity property now if you were asked
for linguistically games played so how
does it work what does it do
the the natural language resolution of
this how does that work so it's got to
do an assuming but the question is does
the assuming have to drill down what is
the symbolic version of um you know what
games that's a case where it has to has
mr. sports played right and that has to
have an aggregator which combines those
two things right that's right so in
other cases there's a so some cases
there's an assuming some cases there's
an aggregator
Michael or anybody else can you comment
on this please
right now that MLB player games played
and NBA player games played are both
separate properties suppose yes we know
that of course they are right so that's
not my point
I mean the question is given that we
start from person right we can know and
presumably we have this information and
the surf we know that that person has
associated that entity has associated
with it these other entities great
John's point is that its intrinsic that
it's coincidental that the MLB player
games played and NBA player games played
properties just happen to have the same
name of games played and so you're not
going to get the total if you ask for
games played you're going to
intrinsically get the assumption
but you know what I think okay so his is
a his acclaim okay so one question is um
is the question you're asking what are
all of the games in any sport this
person has played okay the Knitting of
identical things right that's the real
issue okay so for example you know is it
the case that the second argument of
entity
no it's not the case is not the case it
is not the case sorry it isn't it is not
the case that the second argument of
entity is always unique it's always
always is always always uniquely denotes
a particular thing right that's the
whole rotate is no oh it's normal
hydrogen and molecular hydrogen are
completely exactly but they second
argument on its own no the second
arguments on its own means nothing
there's yeah language types yeah boy so
this entity there element hydrogen etc
okay so this brings us to the whole
question which we were talking about
before which I was talking about before
about equivalences between things
if there was a tight sports and the
property games play it was a property of
that and then the other sports inherited
that property in perhaps it could be it
was exactly that no that's that's
exactly how you get at work you'd have
an athlete type or something yeah it's
not gonna work we kind of guarantee that
kind of hierarchy well so so far with it
well I guess the counter example is the
astronaut thing where the question was
whether astronauts should inherit from
person or whether a person should
inherit from astronaut because you could
also have animal astronauts and then you
have the Associated problem that not all
persons are astronauts and the way you
fix that is you make astronaut be an
abstract entity type and so then you
create an astronaut person entity type
that inherits from person concretely and
from astronauts abstractly and you
create an animal astronaut entity type
similarly and then it just works so so
far we have no counter examples where
this kind of hierarchy doesn't just work
I don't believe it's gonna work I think
what we need instead is something where
we can have you know we're given
we're somehow each thing can say so
sorry I still have problems with
descendants it is not the case because
it is not the case in the sense of right
now in your example or in a theoretical
world like John Smith we don't have a
trans miss we have John Smith's one to
412 and then it's unique we can always
make it unique well I'm saying I don't
think it's a good idea to do that
because I don't think we want these it's
a different story but right right so I
think these two it's perfectly
reasonable that the standard names and
in fact desirable and in fact what we've
done for the last decade and a half is
the standard names here agree the
standard names but yet these things the
whole thing is something different than
this whole thing although they share
many properties
I would say they should know these my
friends that's it
what did you penalty again what do you
mean by chemically roses element I know
I know so maybe that's not the best
example we can take the example we can
take any of these examples to work the
book the manifestation which happens to
be probably a hierarchy there
well it's a hierarchy until the
manifestation is a is a bound copy that
includes three books
right that's different than the person
the MLB player the astronaut because
they are all manifestations right I I
understand look people are special in
the following sense okay and we get
confused it's like Schrodinger with this
cat you know by putting you know the
shortage of cat thing one gets away with
that because everybody sort of knows
that a cat is only is either alive or
dead if it was you know had this thing
boiled or not then you know physicists
who talk about critical phenomena would
say well I don't know that it's boiled
or whether it's you know there's a
coexistence thing between liquids and
gases and so on it's more complicated
people in the current state of the world
are very distinct entities right
ignoring Siamese twins of various kinds
and all that kind of thing but people
people are a great example of a very
unique you know of a no look that there
many kinds of things in the world that
have this property like a lump of gold
for example isn't really you know it can
be subdivided and it's two lumps of gold
whereas
I think there are there are kinds of
things in the world that have sort of
registration IDs like an aeroplane or
something if you cut the airplane in
half it's no longer you don't get two
airplanes right whereas if you cut the
lump of gold in half or even if you cut
to cut a diamond in half do you get you
get two diamonds but that name you know
the Hope Diamond cut in half is not am I
making sense I am I mean yes but if you
like it's a practicality issue like like
a five dollar bill every single one has
a number yet candle you're typically not
interested in the individual but
therefore humans your only interest in
the individual words and not all people
living in your banner I don't agree I
don't agree you might say that that was
the theory you know if you have an army
or something you're interested in sort
of everybody in the third Regiment of
whatever it is and you don't distinguish
necessarily I mean there are purposes
which you distinguish in their purposes
which we don't discuss or example you
say a you know a registered nurse and
you know that's a that's a you know we
need a registered nurse I would consider
this to be a person okay well fine I'm
telling you I think the people case the
case of people I mean like airplanes
okay you may not be personally you know
you know okay this is complicated right
because an airplane you think it's a
Boeing 737 okay it's the same as another
Boeing 737 but yet each one has a
separate tail number
and do you want to consider those
separate or not there's some purposes
which you want to consider it separate
and some purposes which you want to
consider it generically and I think it's
really the same
I mean people I don't know if I can
construct as good an example with people
I mean it depends on various aspects of
ideology how identical you want the
people to be considered to be and so on
but again I don't think there's a strong
notion there's a notion of the airplane
with a particular tail number and
there's a notion of the airplane of a
particular type you know it's relevant
what type it is whether you know if you
are certified to fly that type you can
fly another one with a different tail
number but you can't fly a different
type
but yet if you're counting maintenance
of airplanes you care about the tail
number okay so so where are we going
with all of this um I think the issue is
like even let's consider this case
actually of airplanes
I want to consider that case ok so
aeroplanes of a particular type of a
given type and then airplanes with a
particular tail number and I think even
among types it's some you know there are
airplanes of a general type eg you know
Boeing 737 ok here of a given I don't
even know how these are precisely done
but 737-800 or something um airplanes
with a particular tail number you know I
knew that plane once um the anyway the
ah right so that's a hierarchy of
meanings to a plane
now what happens what is our entity I
mean we currently have
okay aircraft and our aircraft is I
don't know what we what some - do you
have any idea how these well let's take
a look if I say Boeing 737
okay so I wonder what happens if I say
can we understand that no total fail um
what do you think it should Boeing 737 /
800
chuckles huh no what did that
oh that is very confusing guys look at
this oh no it just said that
very confused here does anybody know how
this works
Aylin anybody else my guess is that's
probably a spelling because aircraft
data is a mix of classes and families of
aircraft and other and different
variants that may just be a spelling for
737s in general okay so what do we do
includes variants like data flight data
has oh yo know that there's that even
even more than that a particular trip of
a particular plane
like so it's like all right what's that
it's like meter data Taylor playing
particular plan on a particular route on
a particular date
yes but in flight data what is it deal
it must return planes with tail numbers
Michael
yep is its flight data in 12:1 not yet
um okay but how does it return those
tail numbers is it are they entities or
what only at the level of the plane type
say that against it so then so then
flight data has like molecule it is not
imagining that every plane is a separate
entity like in other words coiffed okay
because okay that's a little bit
complicated because planes okay
obviously having every Vin of every car
be a separate entity is a little crazy
how many cars are like a billion cars or
something maybe more than that but and
we're also making the decision that
planes don't have unique entity
identifies but ships do don't they
right I'm in the the a given aircraft
carrier is its own entity
however a cookie-cutter you know little
yacht thing we we don't think we don't
feel good about that being its own
entity
you
right that makes sense Oh Carl is
pointing out on our live stream that
actually we do have oops that's not what
I meant but he says you have um you can
say we have all the 737 variants because
I was just looking at that - yeah
it's an entity class of Boeing 737
aircraft and there's 737-300 where we
drives okay so my slash was wrong I mean
I think somebody should check that as a
spelling question um whether whether in
fact there the slash should be allowed I
don't know I'm not an expert enough on
these things to know okay so we do have
the 800 series and yet I doubt we have
an inheritance mechanism between the 737
and the 737-800 they're different
entities of the same type so there's no
there's no inheritance between although
there might be an entity class of war
boeing 737 various planes yeah okay so
so in other words are you telling me
that if I say entity class here aircraft
Boeing 737 yep that will be a cloud
includes a number of members so if I
then say entity lists there then I get a
bunch of different kinds where's the 737
max
hmm maybe a curation asou I think it's
grounded yes I know that but so does
that mean
great what is it you know does the
Spruce Goose make it into okay is the
Spruce Goose am
Africanness sake okay so just cuz it you
know that's of course a singular right
that is a an entity class but there's
only one of it but it is a it will have
has a designator and you know for
air-traffic control purposes it no doubt
was if there were even operating at that
time yeah I would have been that would
have had some kind of type designator
okay so let's go back here again to you
know you have so the question is where
did the designation of the entity come
from so it probably came from natural
language and you said Neil Armstrong for
example and then the so let's walk
through the essentially the the flow
flow of knowledge
I'll flow of of let's just call it flow
because I don't really know what it's
flow of okay so you type Neil Armstrong
okay what you might what you get by
default is entity person Neil Armstrong
let's say
but now let's imagine
gosh I am so confused here but let's say
um okay
then the question is if I say if the
input if the input is you know Neil
Armstrong space missions okay does that
become entity person let's find out who
he actually is hold on
oops I went mental or um okay there he
is okay so that is an entity and then
the question is if I now say so does
that query become Neil Armstrong space
Mishra what is the net what is the
actual what's the actual exam space
missions and believe okay alright so
that is probably not gonna shoot it does
work okay how does that work that works
by calling an entity class in manned
space mission data that is named for the
members right man space mission manned
space missions is just a property of
person right now right yes yes oh that's
all right
okay so that's what we do this this goes
back to the thing you said at the
beginning like you think that we
shouldn't have manned space mission
manned space missions art works all
these things for every single person
that's what I think right right is what
we have now okay fine so let's talk
about how we would avoid that okay that
then what would happen in this case is
it would somehow have to indirect to
discover that that say a property I mean
essentially what's happening is it would
have to say if you ask for you know okay
so it would have some kind of
inheritance mechanism you know person
comma manned space missions say go look
and see
an astronaut with that canonical thing
let's say this would go to let's imagine
we actually have a slightly more general
case right so this would then be an
inheritance mechanism that says if
you're asked about manned space missions
for a person look and see whether
there's manned space missions for an
astronaut see what I'm saying
that's pretty straightforward so forth
right but so now if we say for example
okay so now the issue is
let's take our friend well okay we've
got four species we've got all the
species in there and then we'll be
repeating them in the mammal subclass in
the in the mammal sub you know that
we'll have a grizzly bear as a species
and then we'll also have a grizzly bear
as a um as a mammal right I think there
would be a bad idea I would only have to
closely as a mammal and then go up okay
so then would you have Neil Armstrong
not as a person I think that would be a
mistake
no that's different because the person
the Armstrong has poverties that
astronaut doesn't have but the species
grizzly bear has no proble tasted yeah
they're members let us consider that
proposition okay I'm not sure you're
right about that for example it might be
very foolish let's imagine that there's
a bunch of taxonomic information okay it
might be very foolish to replicate that
for every mammal for every reptile etc
that we have this block of boilerplate
stuff that is about its subtext or it's
this it's that it's the other it might
be better to have those associated with
its species instantiation you know
viewed as a species in the Linnaean tree
or whatever these are its sub taxer etc
etc etc but viewed as a mammal this is
its gestation period
I don't quite see how you in the natural
way differentiate properties that belong
to a manner other than to a species
well okay so let's take the example okay
okay so what I'm saying is species
species general properties eg taxonomic
tree properties
and then um what is Mammalia is it a
phylum anybody know
gosh we're so poorly educated okay well
whatever it is I don't think it's right
it's a family or something isn't it not
sure um whatever category mammals um so
here EG gestation period but now what
are you asking if i say grizzly pair
best okay so let's imagine that i input
this is where it gets a little tricky
see this is where i'm pretty sure we
need to have this notion of you know
this is where I'm pretty sure what we've
got is the X plus 1 squared versus you
know x squared plus 2 X plus 1 right
where so in other words I might enter I
might say um you know for example if I
say grizzly bear I'm gonna make
something which is one word koala
gestation period ok it might be that
that wants to turn into entity mammal
you know koala gestation period whereas
if I say koala sub taxa it might want to
turn into entity species koala sub taxa
so that is you know that is the same
thing as saying gold ionization state
copper ionization state because if we
say copper ionization state then we're
pretty much you know we're talking about
an ion if we say copper I
atomic mass we're talking about a single
atom right
but if mammal and hereit's from species
then there's no difference between
entity mammal koala and entity species
koala except that the only difference is
whether or not you're making explicit
that it's a mammal but the
infrastructure already knows that the
entity species koala is a mammal and
vice versa okay but so I claim that
there are properties that might be
different um but then they'll have
different names and that sort of thing
they won't know they will have the same
name and different values and it's yes
well I do yes look look look look here's
how that can happen okay so we say
entity element copper okay entity and
I'm going to this is what we talked
about last time about proteins that do
and don't have a hemoglobin that doesn't
doesn't have its iron in there is that
the protein backbone or is it the thing
with the iron atom in that similarly
here if we have an ion okay
then and I don't know which well but
then it's a different entity what do you
mean it's a different entity
because copper two-plus is not okay okay
let's not use that example okay let's
use the example of si si okay let's try
and use the hemoglobin example and can
somebody fill that in properly for me
what what I'm talking about there it
sounds like you've got tuna wait wait
wait wait a minute is Jason here yes
okay so can you please tell me what the
I mean what I think is the case maybe
I'm wrong is that there what we have
what we represent as a chemical might be
different from what we represent as a
protein because let me give you an
example here okay if we ask what is the
amino acid sequence here the amino acid
sequence does not contain the iron
that's sitting in the middle is that
true statement
this game of last time and I didn't look
it up in between there beforehand I do
believe it does
how come you okay let me give you let me
give you whatever a thyroxine or
something that contains an iodine
there is no frigging iodine in any of
the if I'm not completely confused
there's no iodine in any amino acid the
iodine is not coming from there the
iodine it's it's it's like a you know
little cage and it gets an an iodine
um maybe somebody on the livestream
knows the answer this I'm pretty sure
I'm right about this and that the
protein backbone if I say um you know
amino acid sequence right there is a
perfectly meaningful thing there's
shades of what is hemoglobin no someone
I'm saying there's hemoglobin as a
protein there's hemoglobin as a chemical
we're making sense and each one has a
molecular mass and they will be
different
or you know I could go on many examples
like this and I think what has to happen
is that we need this kind of mechanism
where we say you know this is the
forwarding sequence and maybe it's a
precise forwarding sequence or maybe
it's better to say the result is
approximately such-and-such you know
let's say we have the data for the for
the merkulov weight for the protein case
but not for the chemical case right
better that we do something in that case
and you just say oops we don't know
but this argument does not quote in my
opinion justify building the whole phone
vote Oh No
Michael Michael look look my claim is
okay what is your claim about this never
just looking so it seems to me like
there isn't time include being 50
different labels fully specified okay
fine fine
the UM yes Brian on the live stream is
saying yeah amino acids have no iron
right um
the all right but so looking it up now
he hemoglobin is a metalloprotein which
is the protein which has the the amino
acid backbone and then there's a metal I
am cofactor okay so then this isn't
really so there isn't really a protein
the protein is some kind of globin thing
and this is this is something which is a
complex of some kind right so the the
iron cloning ring is like again okay
fine but but but the thing that I keep
on claiming and I'm pretty sure it's
gonna happen is that we need to have
this idea of forwarding from one you
know so we think of something in this
domain of discourse right Gone with the
Wind
it's a book associated with that book is
a work
and if you ask something like who's the
hero
given the book gone with the wind second
edition hardcover say who's the hero
okay you forward that question to the
work entity type which knows the hero is
whoever
what I'm saying
so my claim is what's needed is that you
come in you know if you're coming in
from natural language you come in with
the best entity type for what you're
talking about but that entity type might
forward to another entity type to
resolve what the value of some property
is
you know in certain cases and that's
again this view of the domain of
discourse thing you know what kind of a
thing and again the criterion for what
you have as an entity type is something
where it's more or less rectangular more
or less all entities have all of those
properties Phil then
now
what about canonicalization what if you
say you know you've got something which
came in as a mammal koala and you got
something came as a species koala and
you say well are those the same thing or
not well the answer is they're not
really the same thing but they are for
some purposes the same thing okay it's
the same issue as you know sodium
chloride as a chemical versus sodium
chloride as a mineral or something
versus whatever else for some purposes
they're the same and some they're not
just like X plus 1 squared and the
expanded form are the same for some
purposes but not for others
so my claim is what's needed is a form
of of resolve or simplify or something
for entities which can determine you
know with respect to this way of
thinking about these things are these
the same and depending on how you're
thinking about it they may or may not be
the same like for example for some
purposes the in particular for some
properties Gone with the Wind the second
edition book is the same as um you know
Gone with the Wind the work but for some
purposes it's not just making any sense
to anybody
oh yeah yeah so my claim is that what we
should be doing is you know okay so that
okay so then what does this actually
look like this means what comes in from
natural language is
one of these entities if you property
eyes it and but by the way this would
solve our problem with concepts from the
image identifiers and things like this
right because it would be the same type
of thing we would it would have a
forwarding mechanism like this that says
this property of this entity type
forwards to this property of this entity
type
now that forwarding arrow okay so that
there's this notion of forwarding and my
claim is that that notion of forwarding
is that that arrow should really have a
footnote about what view of the entity
allows this forwarding or alternatively
that um okay so for example yeah that's
the way to think about it the way to
think about it is that
in property so we could say something
like entity equal
well entity equivalent maybe its entity
equivalent to Q and one and two and then
[Music]
equivalents type what's an analog of
that we've got several analogs of it and
certainly with distances we have an
analogue of that do we have an analog
with equivalences
don't sink same test
maybe yeah okay it's like same test
exactly it's like same test right but
there might be a little bit too limiting
say if you think in historical countries
it is not clear that there's a
one-to-one method between groups of
entities okay all right fine but but the
thing about entity equivalent queue is
what we're saying is given an entity of
a certain type
if we ask for a property
then we have to decide is it
you know when we asked for that property
we might want to qualify how we asked
for that property using this essentially
equivalents type thing because if we say
for instance because sometimes we don't
want to make that that forwarding
sometimes the forwarding is incorrect
depending on how persnickety we want to
be the forwarding might be incorrect
like for instance okay maybe I could try
one okay I've got one sorry the book and
the manifestation okay
the forwarding if you say wait of the
book right the weight of them the mass
of the book the mass of the book you
know as and you know the Amazon store is
whatever but the mass of the book that's
in you know let's say it was um I don't
know that you know some version of the
Bible that was some the mass of the book
um the UM you know the mass of the
particular copy of the book that's in
the such-and-such library which has this
leather binding is going to be different
from the mass of the generic Bible let's
say
or that makes sense but for the purposes
of you know massive book well it's a bad
example John did you have a better
example so let's take our friend mr.
sports and if somebody asks give me all
of the points ever scored by mr. sports
versus all of the touchdowns ever scored
by mr. sports even though mr. sports
this might have the same it might be the
same property for both NBA games and NFL
games they can't one can't be aggregated
versus the other they have to be
forwarded differently based on this
equivalence context
I'm confused by that but that may be
because of my lack of knowledge of
sports comes along dude can you explain
that in a way that I might understand
I'm not entirely sure what what John was
trying to communicate there I'm sorry I
think because the the number of points
of a touchdown is is six and and points
per basket and basketball can be one two
or three if the person was a basketball
player and a football player and you're
asked for the number of points scored
you're gonna get a raw total of points
versus the number of touchdowns scored
you not can get a number of points
scored but the times across the goal
line so making same eye catching at a
higher sports than but that's a good
point
okay so a number of points scored okay
so that then ok so then there is the
notion of sometimes there needs to be
aggregated okay
eg points scored I mean it's kind of
silly because the points are obviously
not but doesn't really matter I mean
that that's some I'm sure there are
other examples that we can come up it
maybe there's a better example I mean
this this seems like a case where if if
if we got asked that question I would
think that we would want to make the
intelligent assumption that that person
is interested in that person's football
career if by asking about touchdowns
they're implying that they have an
interest in football and the sensible
thing would be to look at points scored
for them as a football player not to do
some weird aggregation over every sport
they but let's try it let's try and
think of another case where this useful
aggregation isn't that a different case
the baseball versus basketball you have
two different more specific types that
happen to have coinciding property nine
names so
are different for voting than going to
the from the more general to the more
specific one right yeah well no but I
mean what we're saying is the whole
point about forwarding here is that just
like there's a person to astronaut
forwarding there also is an astronaut to
person forwarding okay we have to get
the other way around as well and
sometimes it won't work both ways round
I predict that there will be some of
these that only forward one way
you shouldn't be able to go I can't
completely think of an example right now
but that you shouldn't be able to go
from you know in other words that these
are you know no show equipped forwarding
slash equivalents that is that you are
got
yeah I mean let's take the other example
which is the image identifier right so
the image identifier I mean we have this
notion of what are we calling them um
well or for text cases for example we
have the notion of and what are we
calling those things interpretation
class what are we calling that
but
yeah there's a lot mission paid for that
it's
content
can I look for that yeah you should go
to takes cases there would be oh yeah
there we go
content types okay
so now
you
how do these relate how do these relate
and by the way why on earth is that
black and the other ones are gray
bug no because for now there is no
Twitter hinder interpreter types but
Berg as has been opening it as a
suggestion
okay fine so we will add that probably
okay so how does this relate to what
we've been talking about here
you
you
neither one earth is that doing wise
what is that type there that looks wrong
because this one has no also interpreter
fight but there are some entity entity
pages but why isn't there an interpreter
there so you're using I'm a bit confused
about what's happening here but let's
not get into that rat hole right now um
actually that's a very interesting thing
so a noun
we don't currently have an entity we do
have elephant as a word don't we
yes elephant is a concept entity to
right we have elephant as a concept a
word and okay so let me give that as an
example okay so down here we've got the
elephant example okay so we have it as a
concept eg for image identify if I'm not
mistaken a word and a species right
anything else we have elephant for I
think that's it but notice that elephant
has a word
I'm not even sure that elephant is like
well I don't know elephant as a concept
or
um
yeah so this is a great example of what
I'm talking about about forwarding
because if you have elephant as a word
and then you say what color is and what
color is that most words don't have a
meaningful color associated with them
right
but elephant happens to have a color
associated with it
so but this relation would be less on
the type level but more on the
individual entity level so avert entity
knows which type it is about what you're
saying yeah okay fair enough fair enough
that's a good example where this notion
of forwarding that says oh boy what a
mess okay okay so in fact I am wrong
no I'm not wrong okay no I'm not wrong
look look you know you have a person
you're asking about manned space
missions about that person okay then you
have to say well let's consider the you
know is there in fact an astronaut
corresponding to that person
see what I'm saying
if yes then find that man specimens from
property there okay consider the
elephant example right so you've got a
word an elephant as a word and then you
are asking what's the color of it so
then what you can ask is is there a you
you're then having to look up
is there a related entity type for which
there is a color property now
conceivably there could be multiple
entity types for which there is a color
property for instance it could be you
know a chemical could have a color
property an animal could have a color
property right so then what you do is
you say okay
for this particular entity elephant does
it have a corresponding um you know to a
corresponding animal entity okay great
which has a color okay great it's gray
okay
does it have a corresponding chemical
entity no it doesn't so nothing to say
there right I'm not sure if it's so easy
because the trying to solve even on to
have an elephant as a fetus well what
you're saying is the Knitting I was
about to bring this up the Knitting of
the correspondence between word the word
elephant and the thing it means
represented as a species entity might
not be okay so let's see what we
actually have exactly like for the for
the person example you can literally go
by this donbot name but you can't do
this for the other things okay so here
for example we have okay assuming
African bush elephant use elephants
plural instead right so the question
here would be let's let's do that again
the question here would be if you if you
have
right so when you say elephant which of
those species specifications does it map
to
right so that means and if I look at
what the input form of these things is
that's probably some complicated
elephant to die yes it is um and this is
probably elephant tada
something or other no okay or whatever
okay all right so that's a good example
so what you're saying then is that
associated with
okay
I think what's gonna happen is this I
think yes it's very much like computer
properties and entity stores okay I
claim there are cases in which there is
a generic forwarding that can be done
there are other cases for which you have
to define for each entity what that
forwarding might be
let me say it again in an entity store
there is a notion of a computed property
where a given property can be computed
for any entity of that entity type right
but there's also we can say let's add a
particular property for a particular
entity that is for a particular entity
not for a whole type of entity so
similarly here I claim there will be
forwarding that is appropriate for a
whole type of entity versus forwarding
appropriate only for a particular entity
I think this particular case might not
be so common or useful because if you
ask what is the color of the word
elephant
well it's indeed not applicable because
the word does not have to precise that's
not what's going to work right for a
particular entity versus a type of
entity see this is exactly where we're
gonna get in trouble okay Tony you
you're trying to okay here's what here's
what is my interpretation of that right
if you try and make the world axiomatic
it will fall apart as in the you know
you're right that the word elephant is
not the same you know welcome to some
linguistic philosophy or something the
word elephant is not the same as
elephant is a concept or you know or the
elephant thing or something I have a
more technical question so in this
example that you gave is the Commerce
data fund though we have to add a fund
say as a built entity and now you want
to cover what exactly do you mean by
this you apply upper case Cola or you
have something districts jump attack am
I talking about here what the hell did
that do you supports amazing right it is
approximately right but how did it do
that okay
there's elephant as a word yeah okay so
how do you now continue this your Cola
example okay so I'm claiming that if I
say for example that sub color so this
means basically sir I'm understanding
like you use this color as a
as a complete standardized property name
or you use this call or trust as an
uppercase version of normal kids call it
doesn't that depend on whether you used
a black pen
a red pen or a blue pen to write it down
what because it's a word I understand I
understand but okay like my baby does
it's called skin color you know it's not
obvious that it's called color I
understand that point but linguistically
look that's what our paws are does okay
so if I say color of an elephant
no idea if that's gonna work but but
let's say I say color of an elephant
that's absolutely mysterious how that
worked I have no idea how that work that
might have been a one-off for something
it means it didn't have a proper past
that we couldn't show that's issues data
extras right because not all of those
those properties are exposed as species
data okay all right well anyway so this
very very bizarre thing if it let's
imagine that in that case we would have
something that was using you know
something like an entity species entity
I'm just writing this out and that and
that's precisely the point is it's using
the species entity and actually the
ignoring the word entity and that's the
right thing to do and in this in this
case you were referring to the species
and not the word I I know that I know
that I know that but what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is this this is my whole
point about entity equivalence and
forwarding okay let's say you got the
word it came out of NLP processing of
some random piece of text okay for
whatever reason you have the word you've
got the word because it's come out of a
synonym tree or something okay and it's
really a word like thing and now you say
oh by the way I want the color of that
you know the color of the thing
corresponding to that word what I'm
saying here is that we should have a
mechanism whereby that
you know yes you're right you could be
completely confused you could really be
thinking of that word as a word written
on paper a specific word as written by
my pen in which case asking for color
that's where I'm talking about what type
of forwarding what equivalent type we're
talking about right so in that case I
think what you really need to do is
interpreter of species of elephant of
color I know but that's not but the
whole point is we don't want to have to
make people do that but but words are
not species I understand we're going to
have to exist at the level of individual
word senses yeah yeah yeah yes yes
that's right
look you're absolutely right a word is
not a species okay but what I'm trying
to say is my claim is that you can't
make that what we have to do is have
this notion that it is a that okay
there's two ways to think about this
either you can do type conversion on the
word and turn it into a species using
interpreter and then go look up its
property and then all's fine but the
question is is there automated type
conversion if you simply ask for the
property yeah what you're asking for is
more than that because because you're
asking you're asking for
reinterpretation right it's not just I'm
strong with the person in an astronaut
no no no I I this is the point I keep on
making okay the point I keep on making
is that this idea of what an entity is
sometimes hydrogen means the thing which
is a combination of isotopes sometimes
hydrogen maybe it's bad example but but
you know sometimes you don't care that
it's a mixture of isotopes that's
probably a bad example sometimes you
care deeply that it's a mixture of
isotopes
okay so depending on the context
depending on the domain of discourse it
can matter which you know you can have
to be very precise or not so precise and
what I'm claiming is that we want a
mechanism for doing operation
on entities that has you know where
where you can you can somehow specify
what level precision you're trying to
deal with in other words how pedantic do
you want to be because there are some
applications for which no pedantry don't
like for example for example you know
like like the speed of an unladen
swallow for instance right you know you
can say or or the you know the the
weight of an elephant right okay let's
take weight of an elephant as an example
so it is my speculation I don't actually
know that African elephants and Indian
elephants are you know have
non-overlapping weights I don't know if
that's the case who knows if somebody
happens to know you can say but but but
you know let's imagine that they do they
have a distribution of weights and those
the distribution doesn't really even
overlap so will you just say what's the
weight of an elephant what do you think
you should get I mean that we can see
what we actually do right now okay there
we go the African bush elephant now if
we would say okay so that in fact
doesn't even give us any choice there so
if I say weight of an Indian is that the
other type
their choice you've got buttons to
choose any singing oh yeah I do yeah I
do I do I do I do
okay so now okay well let's let's see
what that assuming actually has in it
okay so actually they were about the
same weight so those an irrelevant case
here but I mean oh we can do something
else words elephant you can put in a
formula instead that's totally weird but
what we're not offered here which i
think is perhaps wrong is the weight of
an elephant generically so in the food
case we are doing that kind of
aggregation right other words if I say I
know whether this will work way to a
chocolate chip cookie
you do get a choice for that from the
first case because your input was just
weight of an elephant not weight of an
Asian elephant
oh oh oh I see I see I see I see you're
absolutely correct
you looked at the assuming is for the
case where you've made a very specific
input
okay use elephants instead okay so let's
see what happens if I do that
you
that is bizarre what did it do
boy if an elephant put on some weight
it's going to be out of range what on
earth to do there
everybody's mystified yes okay I mean
it's probably dope something different
yeah right okay but in any case the
question that we have here um what is my
point
you I say weight of an elephant and
alright I deal with elephant and I could
need to be pedantic about is it an
African or a or AB or or an Asian one or
I could want to be generic and depending
on what I'm doing like if I say how many
chromosomes does it have or something or
how many you know what is its what is it
some cytochrome C look like or something
like this what is its gene look like
then I really probably care which one
I'm talking about but if I ask um
something like does it have a trunk it
probably doesn't matter
how many legs does it have it doesn't
matter right so I don't need to be
pedantic if I'm asking for the number of
legs
sometimes you can only figure this out
by is on knowing some inheritance or by
knowing or by explicitly comparing the
values
let's talk about the aggregator for it
for a second okay so that's a different
thing
so one thing is
okay let's be clear you know there is an
elephant as a word right that's where we
started the elephant is a word now the
question is what
um
okay elephant is a word and now we're
trying to find out the cytochrome C you
know genome did gene gene sequence for
that thing so that we will not be able
to answer without asking for an assuming
without making an assumption
you
um
you
if we asked okay so what is different
cases right so different cases of what
happens okay we can say you know cite
okra you know gene sequence we can say
so that means that requires an
assumption requires choosing or it or it
has to or has to return a list okay
the range either gives the Union or
requires to Zn
well I'd optionally requires choosing
I probably gives the the union where
does that where the elephants live right
okay so next case would be uh the wait
okay so there it could give could give
the overall range which is what we do
for food
or
could require choosing or could return a
list
well anything could require choosing but
it could the most natural thing there
would be to give the overall range which
is an analogous to be aware does an
elephant live you give the union of the
places so I claimed depending on the
property if there are multiple
interpretation so this forwarding notion
is perhaps not right because perhaps
what should be happening is that word
elephant as a word should have multiple
for wordings that it could go to yeah
this is the right thing elephant is a
word has multiple places it can forward
to okay if you look for a particular
property and that property is only valid
for one of those forwarding directions
then that's what you use if the property
is valid for multiple forwarding
directions then you have to aggregate I
climb ie key conceptually am sequencer
on about how completely the poor body is
spelled out okay let's come to that in a
second but but so we've come to a
partial conclusion here so what we're
saying is um given a
entity there may be multiple for
wordings
for that entity
um if a given property is in
uh several of these it requires an
aggregator right now so the question
then is and actually we've already done
this I mean we've aligned entered
elephant as a word least elven is a
concept we've aligned with elephant as a
species correct
what happens if I do the following if I
say if I say picture of an elephant okay
okay it's giving me an African bush
elephant okay hello which is indeed
aligned with the the species data
entities
okay now I do an image identify on that
and I'm going to get hopefully why is
this taking so long
an African bush elephant now what is
that African bush elephant that we see
before us here okay so that's a concept
but annoyingly this one here oops um
this thing here I predict is not whoops
yeah right so with the output for image
identify if yes for the equivalent
entity you should get that that species
entity right so percent 108 equivalent
entities there right right okay and that
will be the right thing okay but this is
what I'm saying is that this we've
already got you know jr. versions of
this whole forwarding mechanism that I'm
describing you know
that's um you know so I'm saying what we
need to do is to generalize this idea of
equivalent entity right that's
essentially what this forwarding
mechanism is is an equivalent entity
thing
so make sense
and and then um what ok so then that the
question is you know whether one allows
a given forwarding may depend you know
on one's pedantry level so to speak
right given what one's trying to do
there may be a level of pedantry where
one does not want to allow that
forwarding
and it also might depend on that solid
the depths of an entity like vistas
elephants we have trust to things but
assume the entity the original entity
would have been mammal and the next
question would have been how do they
taste so we probably get six members
back where we have a taste and 800,000 W
don't have one so what do you to turn
off the our creation okay let's look at
this one let's they taste here
okay I think that in that particular
example the aggregate the only
meaningful aggregate will be an
association of the particular results
you get
because generically you can say what
does
I don't know what does the seabird taste
like and my guess is I don't actually
know and I wouldn't eat those things but
my guess is that they all taste somewhat
similar
at some level
whereas
so in other words that you know what
does the mammal taste like well pork
tastes different from beef you know we
make that distinction I have no idea
where the different kinds of rodents
taste different
I don't particularly want to find out
either um but you get what I'm saying in
other words it's not self-evident that
they don't aggregate but this is kinda
like this thing all cases kinda trivial
application I agree I agree but that's
that's look this is the point but the
gene sequence you can't actually
probably contact okay okay this is a
very good case the gene sequence is a
good case because it could be that these
species do not differ in that gene that
there is not a single difference in the
reference sequence for the species for
that gene but it could be full of it
could be riddled with differences so I'm
saying so if there's no difference you
just return the gene if there is a
difference what do you do well in the
case of Genet genomics there well for
snips at least there is a notation right
for it could be an A or a G type thing
but if you go beyond snips if it's more
complicated transformation I don't think
there's a way to return it in the
aggregate but similarly you know there's
certain kinds of things that will
aggregate like an interval of numbers
will aggregate right
so I I don't know how we represent you
know given you know again if we're
aggregating two things let's let's
imagine that the Asian and African
elephants you know the one of them was a
pygmy elephant and the other one was a
big big elephant and then the
aggregation will probably lead to a
bimodal distribution of weights for
instance and then it's not obvious what
we do it's fairly stupid to say there's
a range that goes from a hundred pounds
to three tonnes or something right when
when it's mostly whether the hundred
pound guys and then there are the
multi-ton guys so you know again we can
imagine an aggregator that I mean we can
imagine an aggregator that will object
if it sees things like the hundred pound
ones and the three ton ones says I won't
aggregate those but if it's a 2.5 ton
one and a 3 ton one it might as well I
go get those
so that's a whole whole set of you know
aggregation choices um and we've got uh
you know eg pygmy elephants I don't even
know if there are other pygmy I think
there are pygmy elephants um I think
they're real oh that's right you are
correct
yes it's one of the extinct species okay
pygmy elephants versus big elephants um
you know it's basically silly to
aggregate weights
you
but you know Asian versus African way
about the same actually a good a good
example of this would be dog breeds
right yeah I thought and where how much
does a dog weigh weight of a dog you
know so they're between this Chi watch
Chihuahua and the descent Bernard you
know let's see if we say weight of a dog
okay to to 160 pounds by the wine earth
are we giving one point six times ten
for two there as opposed to 160 anyway
so if I now say st. Bernard because I
can't spell Chihuahua
you
great um st. Bernard dog okay and now I
say wait oh look at that look at that
it's got male weight and female weight
and I bet if I just say wait this was
exactly my point from earlier okay
that's why I asked 60 days there do you
get this thing form I feel like that's a
critical question I do yeah so you're
saying if I simply ask for the weight of
a person Bernard it's gonna say do you
want a male or a female okay so you
create a whole new set of properties
that are fallible well we may have to do
that I mean we may have to do something
here you know that that's some let's see
wait a minute property forward ability
okay so then we're saying weight versus
male weight versus female weight etc so
you're saying that for the simple answer
if I say let's take a look at what
happens if I say weight of a scent lace
and Bernard
oh for goodness frigging sake who was he
anyway um that is very silly it should
have noticed there was us and Bernhard
weight of a st. Bernard
oh my gosh look at that you didn't say
where he wanted to weigh his
what the heck is that that's the
craziest thing okay that is a very very
okay okay let's look at the assuming
here well why did it do that that's just
completely crazy what it did there okay
no I found an occasion and for the
location it can use do you have any data
to take you get it
Matt's okay okay well that's very very
silly oh I see I see I see I see there
it is the height of sunburn of the city
and it's okay where was that is it food
yeah yeah everything clear okay but now
in this particular case okay so that's
offering me female weight weight versus
male weight um the
yeah that's really confused that parse
by the way okay but in the case in this
particular case what you're saying is
Yankee match our language we have enough
layers in between where we can figure it
out but once we are involve on language
and we have the uppercase swingweight
now we have to do quite non-trivial work
if there's not that well okay so look
the fact is I'm cheating here because
what we really should be doing is that
should be an entity property and just
like the entity forwarding there should
be four word ability what do I mean by
this
that makes sense but then the question
is again where do you get this if you do
just natural language there's a chance
but if you write this thing it gets hot
no no I I don't think you look we might
as a courtesy let you write the string
but I don't think that's the right way
to think about it I think the right way
to think about it is the correct form is
a yellow box brackets the yellow box
okay there might be a courtesy of having
a string there but it is merely a
courtesy there's some precise meaning to
that so if it's a yellow box associated
with a given entity type because
remember the properties are associated
with an entity type so again yes it's
the exact same thing look at this watch
this this is going to be let's imagine
we say entity
hold on I'm thinking here
you
know what I'm what I'm trying to come up
with okay
is and then this is an entity property
for an astronaut you don't seem to have
okay and then this is space missions or
something now okay
so that has to do some forwarding right
because there it's got to say right fine
has the can this person be translated
into an astronaut
if yes apply their entity property
but now imagine and this sounds very
sparkly that there isn't a direct
connection here that is that what am I
trying to say
anybody understand what I'm trying to
say I mean that my claim is that in this
case it's very clear what you do maybe
not a direct subclass but a indirect one
they'll give me an example
a certain substance that is a medicine
which in turn is a chemical okay I
understand so this is drug dosage here
and this here is a chemical for example
even that that would probably be have a
corresponds as well although although
again you see this is a good example
drugs and chemicals okay
the you know people say okay let's take
I don't know what something or other
which is a generic right that versus I
don't even know aspirin for example I
don't know whether the what is the the
salicylic acid or whatever it is right
when you buy an aspirin made by Bayer or
somebody does it is it just a lump of
salicylic acid no I don't think so I
took it as a bunch other credit it
doesn't it oh absolutely especially by
this example extra-strength aspirin
contains a delayed release because you
don't want that full dose all at once
and yet everybody thinks that they
should take the extra strength because
there's more aspirin in it
okay that's interesting but okay so
that's a good example then of something
where again it's a level of precision
question a level of pedantry question if
I say what's the others perhaps a bad
example with drug dosing because when
probably wants to give lots of assuming
x' to get that right but but let's
imagine it was the molecular weight of
an aspirin of aspirin you know is it the
average molecular weight of all the
things in the aspirin pill is it the you
know I visit salicylic acid is that the
right name I forget anyway um acetyl
salicylic acid I don't know I don't know
anything about chemistry there well
actually this is a chemical so that's
who knows what this is okay so what do I
say if I say aspirin as a drug what do
we not know that because it isn't a
prescription what do we do in that case
which says a chemical that's weird well
okay whatever um so then we must have
forwarding in this case because I bet we
have some things about toxicology or
well what do we have here I mean you
know it's does this have drug properties
as well right so long ago there was a
separate peclet for drugs but before I
got here it was folded into a chemical
data so there are plenty of proper
printing of entities in in chemical data
that we'll have just missing properties
for all the drug properties I see but if
I take a drug I don't know what um ah
what's that um oh my god what's that
mean come on Tylenol right that's good
no I want something which is really
definitively a drug um what the heck is
that standard antidepressant um
Prozac the right answer that parses to
the the active ingredient they were
aligned that way but rather than as
whereas ideally you would have a
separate entity that was for the drug
Prozac that would be aligned that would
have a property pointing to that
chemical
which is again what we keep on saying
because at some level prozac means flu
of flu
fluoxetine right which has a molecular
weight it has this and that on the other
right it has you know microstructure all
those kinds of good things what happened
bigger molecule what I'm just curious um
the oh boy it's big I know not so big
and trusting okay um
but the fluoxetine chemical wouldn't
have a ideally it wouldn't have a daily
recommended dosage property yeah I
wouldn't have a packaging property or a
pill shaped properly right but if we you
said fluoxetine pill shape what should
we do
they mean so if they if we did have
separate entities for them they should
be aligned and they should right but
then then it's got to forward because
it's got to be a level of per pedantry
that's got to be a pedantry level
defined because you could say fluoxetine
you know pill shape that doesn't mean
anything
or you could say oh you must mean prozac
pill shape and be happy with it right
right I think you'd have to go further
to dosage forms right depending on
whether it's like 10 milligrams or 50
milligrams yeah yeah right but okay fine
so so that's a case where in that
particular case the aggregator by the
time you're asking pill shape and it's
got a drug then the aggregator has got
to decide what to do so for example it
could be the case that you know all
prozac pills are green right in which
case there's no you can just say what's
the color of prozac Oh fluoxetine pill
it's green all good but it could also be
that the the different dosages are
different colors and then it's got a
whole different thing to go over and
then the aggregator can't just return I
mean one thing that's awkward to me is
in this aggregator business you know as
you write a program the thing that
bothers me is that you know if it could
be well it could be a single thing or it
could be a list or it could be a
interval or whatever that's very hard to
deal with in a program
and it bothers me that you know the
alternative is to say that the return is
always I think what we're going to have
to do is use the third argument identity
entity value because that is the I mean
you know you govern I'm saying about in
a sense how pedantic is the aggregation
you know sometimes it'll just be give me
a thing the best thing you've got
another time it will be give me the most
the most information you can making
sense
so I think that's another you know so
there's a a level of pedantry
for aggregation i'ii give maximum
information eg an association or
something like this or give it your best
shot
etc we unfortunately have to wrap up
soon here but although we're really on a
roll and I would like to get a few
people's opinion I actually think we're
actually getting pretty close to
something reasonable here
Michael some summary from you
ass engine starts alright good I'm still
not so quite clear how we concretely
want to go forward honestly like right
after reaching the things was discussing
the the entity types like like do we
want to create new ones yeah I think the
answer let's I think we're not gonna get
to all of this today but I think what we
got here is we've got a new kind of
superstructure which is this forwarding
mechanism we've got basically the
decision that we should break entity
types up more than we have now
we should rebate because remember the
criterion for an entity type an entity
type is something where the property
value table is roughly rectangular and
not too ragged so for example in the
case of drugs you know you can't
aggregate the entity type of drugs and
chemicals because drugs have all kinds
of properties that most chemicals don't
have does that make sense therefore by
the definition by our sort of contract
about what an entity type is those
should be broken into separate entity
types yes okay so similarly for the
different types of you know mammals
versus birds versus whatever those
should be broken now it could be and and
the whole point is that we have to allow
the possibility I mean we also have to
think about future compatibility and so
on in a world where let's imagine that
somebody thought that yeah his is a
here's a typical horror okay
the taxonomist fight and they eventually
decide that it no a koala is not a bear
you understand what I'm saying so in
other words it used to be that a I don't
know a platypus was considered a reptile
or something but now it's going to the
duck-billed platypus was considered a I
don't think that's right I don't even
remember what it's um you know it's it's
on the border between Maryland reptile
um and so you know some somebody or
let's say Pluto as a planet right Pluto
used to be a planet but now it isn't how
do we deal with that in
in other words if somebody had the
entity planet comma Pluto but wouldn't
have happens in that case right now
um pattered bility um okay so let's try
that entity planet what did we do in
that case I think just a minute well it
isn't mine a planet NOW but maybe we
maybe the the the degrading of Pluto
happened before we defined our entity
types but you understand what could
happen there yeah we define it Pluto as
a planet and then some bright spark you
know the International Astronomical
Union or something suddenly decides no
no that's wrong it's actually a minor
planet right so then what do we do in
that I think we have to have we have to
expect that going forward we will always
maintain the previous entity because
somebody might have code that contains
that burnt in entity
and we probably want some mechanism for
obsoleting an entity but it can't be you
know maybe it generates a message or
something if the entity is used I don't
know but that's another thing we have to
think about um okay could I just ask a
few other people who were here their
opinions about this um the the natural
language processing folk um Jerome
Jerome is still here or um your employer
and dropped out um okay um do you have
any opinions about this yes I mean
actually things discuss here recover be
that one needs four takes place as well
so here are key it's pretty clear that
we need a year our key also the fact for
this piece in the beginning of all that
memo can also be an entity this happens
I mean
see that for text cases we might want to
say not necessarily a specific entity
but something a bit more like a type
like I want over okay we could say all
the infrastructure like name the
infrastructure like these building
listings or all the infrastructure type
that finds all the you know mentions of
a bridge or anything else wait you're
saying well I I'm confused yes I don't
know if it's clear and if it's clear
it's what's things we discussed that was
mentioned in the middle of the meeting
and I thought this would be useful for
text cases well let's take a thick
animals versus mammals okay you might
easily want text cases to say finally
all the animals mentioned here yeah is
that the kind of thing you meant as
opposed to find me all the mammals yes
but but like if it's written squirrel we
might want to have this rather than an
existing memo whereas name I mean yeah
in that case I would work yes yes yes so
in some cases ambiguity like for
infrastructure they could be so much
residual by the name right and okay okay
okay so what you're saying is okay
that's a good interesting case all right
so let's say let's say text cases all
right um
find me all mammals in the passage okay
and then the question is does lassie
okay so one thing is the st. Bernard or
the golden retriever whatever it is and
another thing is Lassie I know it's but
like that isn't it
or Leica or whatever right those are
specific named dogs yep that's
interesting yeah that's an interesting
case would you want if you said find me
all the mammals do you want the
particulars like Lassie I think you
might reasonably want that but that's at
that
pretty interesting actually that some
that because that say you know one is
find me all the mammal entities because
lassie is not a mammal entity last see
what what is lassie lassie is a famous
animal or something is that right Allen
do you remember sorry like you're famous
organism did I spell that right how is
that poor dog's name spelt
okay lassie is a fictional character but
let's see if that is that the only
lassie was not a real I know Leslie
wasn't a real dog but don't okay let's
take a what was that what was the name
of the dog on the Russian spacecraft
thingy it was like you're spelling it
right but I think that mean that do we
not have a famous organism exposed in
the language it's possible do you think
it's in wolf now for but not some it is
yeah there we go
yeah okay so that maybe is not okay so
that's a bug basically that that isn't
exposed yeah I'm okay but that's a
particular anyway so the issue is should
you write that's actually a pretty
interesting case because mammals where
lassie we characterized as a fictional
character whose type happens to be dog
so yeah in the you know six cases
ontology I mean this is kind of a
tentativa data-driven ontology would
have a different entity type but you
could have infrastructure yes I would
refer to the specific named
infrastructure and infrastructure
that will have bridges you know I mean a
bunch of words that are in fact yeah
right right right right right
you could have also concepts as so so
many theta is adding I don't know you
know other field like mathematical
concepts or physic concepts so
infrastructure concepts would would kind
of work as well here but right that's a
separate discussion about the LP concept
annotation thing okay fine so that's
interesting all right comments from
other people what about from Tony you
having a 10 a.m. graph database see
comments here about
paragraphs about the identifier Xander
stability this is tricky because we are
talking about the type first and then
about the entity if we want stable
identify the ability we would need
something like optional typing it should
be something like just the identifier
for the thing and later we have a
property that says okay it's of that
type and that type and data no I don't
agree I mean look at the time went okay
let's imagine human numeral whatever
that thing was called the asteroid that
went through the you know the solar
system whatever it was right let's say
at first that is identified as a comet
then it's identified as an asteroid then
it's identified as something else I
don't think there's a problem in us
saying it's an entity a comet entity now
we might want to say that that entity
has been deprecated but that doesn't
mean that the entity I mean this is a
question I don't know it's one of those
classic philosophy type questions right
the isn't the classic one the king of
France is bald but France may not have a
king and that you know there's a sort of
failure of reference type thing
but I think what we do what we should do
is perfectly happily say great it was a
maybe that's a different issue actually
now that I think about it the
although that is an interesting case for
us this King of France thing um
because what on earth we do in that case
right now
you
funky funky funky funky I mean not
completely crazy but um what happens if
we ask for but if we asked for King of
France or does this yet work in 1678
does that work yet no not yet that will
work right ready
um I mean that will work do what we do
what we do on the website is we give a
data not available but then there's a
pod that's in train that says who the
current leaders of France are what those
what those titles are and who the people
are you open that position right okay
and it also gives another pod with um
with the Kings fair enough
that makes sense I mean that's a very
good thing to do but but for purposes of
our entity framework I think that
something which is identified as a
particular entity type type but then the
world's wise people get together and
decide it isn't actually of that entity
type that doesn't seem to me to be a
fundamental problem is that what you
were referring to Tony yes
because by definition field is not a
planet anymore and deprecating it seems
a little bit hmm yeah like a mistake if
something is deprecated it looks like a
mistake has been made
well index it mistake it was a mistake I
mean I the I mean the whole Pluto a
planet Fiasco I mean who knows what one
I I could tell you some backstory to
that but anyway let's not do that but
but um I'm almost led to tell a funny
story but anyway um the person who was
responsible eventually for deciding that
should be deprecated had gotten into
astronomy as a result of interacting
with the person who discovered Pluto
there's a bizarre factoid for you but
there's a bit part of that story but
anyway the UM if we have
of an entity called Pluto as a planet it
once was considered to be a planet it's
not embarrassing to us to have that
entity be present in our system and if
that entity perhaps generates a message
saying actually this thing has been
deprecated you should refer to it as a
minor planet instead then you're doing
pretty much exactly what the peasants
would want you to do aren't you
I will see a problem with that I am not
convinced
like maybe they added linguistics level
but it turning it if you ask for the
planet would be 34 returning what if you
ask for the planet Pluto wait a minute
okay let's imagine that at time T okay
oommen how does that print thing get
pronounced anybody know how to pronounce
it uma Numa whatever it was you know you
guys know what I'm talking about this
cigar shape yeah okay we've had a really
silly name I think these things are
intended to be you know okay so let's
imagine it was aluminum er um the okay
nobody knows what it is right so maybe
it's somebody will eventually have a
classification interstellar asteroid or
something but right now that thing would
be considered what an asteroid probably
could be considered a comet perhaps but
what it is um in the you know if we have
uma Numa has a comet and later on the
International Astronomical Union says
well actually it's an interstellar
asteroid we've made a new category so
what so we just say that those things it
gets a forwarding to the interstellar
asteroid category and perhaps if
somebody were to have a piece of code
that used the comet designation we might
want to warn them with a message saying
that they should really use that other
designation instead but if it came from
linguistics will simply change the
interpreter and it will now go to an end
so stellar asteroid type that's all fine
but if you do do some statistics on
planets you don't want to be off by one
planet ah good point
okay that's a good point
all right so then okay yeah what if you
asked about planets in the aggregate I
mean that I'm afraid is revealing the
difference between an entity class and
an entity type well I'm afraid that they
okay that this is a different topic I
think I think I mean the main issue here
is going to be um classes of things
versus named types of things
that's gonna end up being an issue I
agree because I would claim that planets
is more accurately a sort of computable
class rather than its
you know other words there's the notion
of where did the name come from and then
there's the notion of what are its you
know what type of thing is it so for
instance what's a good example I mean
there must be okay here's a question
does anybody know the answer to this in
the world of texana mists if they get it
wrong and they call it a you know a well
actually yeah so so I know in ordinary
you know there are things called things
like the false melon volumed there's a
type of type of
Oh weird I thought that was a thing it's
a
that
really weird what it did that was really
weird anybody understand that let's see
whether we know what a melon value tis
um
it's really weird all right let's try my
favorite
somebody hasn't done linguistics for
molluscs
well that's not good Alan like I think
that's in your area I didn't see what
you were probably in mind yeah all right
a bit of an embarrassment with some
mollusks there but in any case the what
happens in you know in in common names
is you get ridiculous things like the
fall smellin volume which is a type of
mollusk and and it's called that because
it was often misidentified as a melon
volume and then it got the weird name of
the false melon volume but the question
is the underlying Linnaean you know
binary nomenclature classification if
they discover that it actually isn't a
melon volume what do they do
does anybody know Michael I'm pretty
sure years ago we talked to various
taxonomist when we were first trying to
do this I don't remember yeah I don't
remember either
so I mean okay but that that's the same
you know um I mean like like for example
it must be a lot of genetics so we can
look that up but there it'd be
interesting to know I mean do they leave
it in the wrong place or do they try and
move it and if they move it what happens
to all the specimens there are in jars
with labels written in the 1880s right I
mean one assumes that there must be a
forwarding mechanism because you know
the jar that's sitting there that has
the the thing in format you know in
formalin or whatever um you know the you
know they're they're wonderful type
specimen that's sitting in the you know
in the basement of such since a true
Natural History Museum is going to have
a particular label even if they got it
wrong so I think we have the same issue
um okay any any further further comments
from Tony well there was a
I had thought about those dated things
but if you want to discuss it now let's
not discuss dated I mean yeah okay so
Mohammed on the live stream is
suggesting the dated of entity planet
entity Pluto common now could return the
Minor Planet um ah Brian is telling me
how to pronounce this Hawaiian name okay
Oh Moo ah
muah Oh mwah mwah
okay thank you I will try to remember
that Oh moolah moolah um parents
Hawaiian okay
what's interesting they um
okay let's see
enter themselves be dated
yeah Mohammed is suggesting just as
entered a property can be dated it would
be nice to have entities themselves
related yeah I mean we discussed that
actually earlier in the session um we
agree about that but the notion that an
entity that's an interesting idea
that a see that that's not gonna solve
the problem I mean even if we said dated
of entity um you know planet III claim
this is gonna get as messy as any of
these other things if we try to say see
that no no this is not gonna work um
goes to the Minor Planet case um that's
not gonna work because if we say dated
of what's a good example dated of
Carthage you know the historical country
of Carthage um now what does it give
what should it give what is the
corresponding
you know and then the question there is
what is the modern dated version of
Carthage isn't Carthage in what's now
Libya they're right
so this going to default to the
country
you
is this gonna do the right thing
yeah how cool apparently it's in Tunisia
I will look at that what a mess what are
we going to give see look at that they
captured a pieces of that's right in
fact one knew that they capture pieces
of Italy as well
so so okay so what is so that raises the
question what okay so you say dated
entity historical country Carthage
common now what does it give complicated
anyway
um and even more okay but dated entities
is clearly a good idea okay who else
would like to comment here um anything
from the well Aaron or Joshua
Josh um and a thing from from that from
you guys
what one thing that I wonder about to
maybe kick around a little bit is how we
can use the backbone of concept data for
for aiding these crosswalks we already
have like we saw with the image identify
of the African elephant the equivalent
entities and such and we can expand on
that and hang a lot of things off of
concept data entities and we already
have a hierarchy built up in there yep I
agree that's a good point that those
already have a hierarchy I mean I agree
there's gonna be a big curation effort
of these forwarding things but that's a
good place to start
yeah a lot of yeah a lot went into
making that and still need some work to
clean up the hierarchy a little bit but
you know it's it's not work I don't
think that we should cast aside and by
the way that stuff does shoroma
and etienne and so on do you know for
Texas you know about the hierarchy stuff
like the notion of an animal that's a
hierarchy above elephants and
rhinoceroses and so on are we using that
in the case of yet not yet but were you
aware of that or is that not um yeah I
mean it's difficult even the data that
not be useful to us okay fine but and we
are discussing with ya people in the
Croatian team about this
okay all right okay other people with
comments here um any comments from the
Massey folks who are here James
Ian
I think this forwarding thing is a good
idea but it doesn't address my u-k's
my use case which is reasoning about
relationships between classes themselves
example like topological space
properties you could have the class of
how store spaces in class of t1 spaces
and there's like arbitrary logical
relationships between them you might
want to say that such and such a space
is in certain classes and automatically
deduce what other classes it is and is
not a member of ok let me think about
that so your point is that in the world
of in most of these things like the
classification of animals is simpler
than the classification of topological
spaces it has less structure than the
classification of topological spaces is
that they is that the meta claim well it
it's hierarchical whereas the
relationship between topological spaces
is not hierarchical it's like you can
say that some classes are subclasses of
others or equivalent to intersections of
you know yeah I understand so this is
mathematical data mathematical knowledge
and the hierarchy is not so relevant
it's less relevant and there's a more
complicated set of relations I mean
obviously we know let's say
computational complexity classes we know
that you know you know P is in NP and
things like this um
I mean that's another absolute can of
worms as things where we don't know if
there's you know P versus NP you know is
it is it strictly inside or is it you
know subset or subset equal that's
another kind of worms or things that
aren't known like that right
that was why I brought up the example of
woman mother and parent that's the basic
kind of relationship you would see like
I tell you that someone is a parent and
a woman and I want to deduce that they
are a mother okay how general I mean
where else okay we've got parent and
woman
implies mother it's equivalent right
it's a cool on both ways
for now it depends on the state of I
don't even know the answer not get into
gender politics
um the okay um okay but but alright so
but what do you think
so what would you like to have for your
mathematical purposes is there some
aspect of this I think maybe that's a
separate discussion I mean okay so
that's a that's an important thing that
we pinned on the side yeah should be
separate okay discussion okay anybody
else here want to want to make comments
before we wrap up this meeting I have
one more another three probably most
people did not agree with it but I think
there's one for me and entity is a
little bit like a pure quantum state in
the following sense you have a wave
function and it a hundred percent human
it's a pure one or the mixed state it's
a hundred percent describes to think but
without having a commuting set of
operators that define what you measure
there's nothing what you can say yet
about it you need properties that
describe the sink in that measure and
this commuting set of operators as we
know from conch pecker can be if
mutually so that that you can do
different things and one property is not
enough to fully specify the other ones
well there's a there's parts of that
analogy that do seem reasonable that is
you don't know what you have until you
start asking in other words you you
don't saying there's a notion of an
entity and you don't know what you have
until you start making until you start
asking about properties of it no you
don't know detective what you have to
pay for this all that you ever have that
is not more than it you know everything
but you don't know any of its poverty in
some sense okay all right so where do we
go with this analogy that kind of like
it's like this different kind of formal
things and how to few things it's kind
of it's a complete commuting set of
operators that you measure on it I say
so you
concern is that essentially that we are
going to burn in something which denies
some entity analog of entanglement yes
you know that's not a bad phrasing yeah
or that basically which is already fully
specified it doesn't allow things like
just measuring the energy you we also
require we also measure the angular
momentum yet we have not done too much
specification yet well I understand so
you're saying if you say what does it
weigh but you haven't said whether it's
African or Asian as an elephant yet is
that what you mean no it's more like
some of the properties might be like the
thing is already specified but the
property is are still fluffy with
respect to formatting
I don't understand why we come up with
some example for next time okay but I
mean that the main issue that we have
look the main meta point here is we
don't want to burn into our framework
some assumption about the world that
simply isn't true definite now to be
fair in all these years you know our
basic entity property mechanism while it
has you know creaked around the edges
and that's what we're worrying about
right now we have been able to
successfully describe a lot of stuff
with it and you know in a sense weird
corner cases you know we probably can
get around the weird corner cases and
there will be weird corner cases I claim
it's inevitable there are weird corner
cases you know is it a solid or liquid
is it a you know oh we know it's a glass
whatever um fair enough all right well
we should probably wrap up I mean this
is this is about as close as that you
get to you know applied philosophy or
something
the I mean this is there's probably uh
you know it's kind of lovely actually
how um how philosophically complex a
bunch of these things get or somebody
asks on the live stream any countries
with common intersecting board
I'm not sure I understand that I better
be the case that countries are disjoint
I think that's the nature of um you know
no doubt mill to ash it's a question do
military conflicts align themselves with
the borders of historical countries um
who knows and oh oh I see
I see you're talking about like the
Demilitarized Zone and you know what the
heck do we do with that what country is
that is the DMZ in
Allen that will be for you or like
regions of international airports if we
punt mostly I mean if it's genuinely
disputed areas we we have a definition
of the those particular areas yeah but I
bet legally I bet the treaty that
established the DMZ I wonder whether
that's in both whether that's
considerably in South Korea or North
Korea the DMZ is in both countries
because there's a building that sits on
the border where they can come and have
conferences okay so it fine well okay
but that okay so if HAARP it's a
different kind of entity yeah but right
but that means there is a border line it
just happens to be the case that that
building straddles the border line so it
is not the case that there that there's
a given lat/long coordinate which is in
two countries um and I know this with
bench or sit what did Ben just say that
there's a place there is a piece of
there's a lat/long coordinate which
where if we say geo where if oh my gosh
what a mess okay well we say geo
identify of that that it should return
two countries I mean there must be some
representation of spun-off Starsky and
Josie yes bring that up Aiko but it's
it's some right ignoring issues of the
continuum um
I mean yeah well anyway um all right
well we should wrap it up here thanks
all we will obviously need to go on but
I think we've made some good progress
and thanks to early in the meeting
thanks to folks on the livestream for
all kinds of comments and until the next
time see you all soon